uh junior doctors have begun three days
of strike action today and the health
secretary Steve Barkley has just been
speaking uh and let's have a listen to
what he has to say
well it's frustrating that they all were
Keen to engage with the junior doctors
we recognized the huge pressure the
workforce has been under through the
pandemic we've made an offer of talks
with them to discuss pay on the same
basis as we have with the other health
unions those other health unions have
accepted whether that's the RCN Unison
GMB unite have been having discussions
with government on pay the junior
adopters have chosen not to do so and I
urge them to come and have those
discussions with me as a matter of
urgency so the BNA says that offer came
at 10 to 10 on Friday why was it so late
no we discussed with them I had a
meeting with them for example on the
12th of January where we talked about
the need to look at pay for 23 24. there
has been a separate discussion in terms
of this year the 22-23 which was covered
by a multi-year prb a pay review board
decision so that was closed we were
looking to discuss with them uh this
coming year with the other health unions
we have listened to their concerns in
terms of this year that's why with them
we've been discussing this year and next
year together as a package we've made
exactly the same offer to the junior
doctors but so far they've refused to
engage in those talks
so the BMA is asking for a 35 pay rise
and you've said that's not affordable I
think people will want to know how this
can end is there a figure that you can
say is Affordable that might lead to
negotiations might lead to a deal well I
don't think a 35 pay demand is
Affordable and for many of your viewers
uh that will ring uh very strange in
terms of what they themselves have had
in their job so 35 as a demand is not
affordable we've offered to engage in
constructed talks with the junior
doctors We Stand ready to have those
discussions and they should urge them to
come and engage with us on that so yeah
with other health unions and is it not
really a matter of time until you engage
in you do you have these talks with this
Union can this not just happen now and
avoid this disruption well the Junior
adopters can come in and have those
discussions we are in negotiation with
the other health unions we've been
engaged in constructive and meaningful
discussions with them and I urge the
junior adopters to do likewise to come
in to discuss these issues but pause
their strikes in order to do so